[Música]
hace muchos años
vivía en puebla en un pequeño pueblito
llamado santana rodeado de muchos
animales y también de mis perros
ahí aprendí a ver aprendí a observar a
los animales y con el tiempo cuando
llegó aquí a tijuana tengo mi primer
perro compré una perra pensando que iba
a ser mi hija me casé mi esposo y yo
teníamos una hija que era una perra y
era una perra
pusimos el césped a los no se lo puse en
la mañana cuando llegó en la tarde del
trabajo el césped estaba todo apilado y
dije que pasó y la perra toda llena de
tierra y dije el pp me las vuelvo a
acomodar y me vuelve a hacer lo mismo al
día siguiente la manguera del agua la
rompió bueno era un caos y me puse a
investigar cómo hacer para poder tener
educada mi perra me costó mucho trabajo
fueron 34 años y de repente ya había
educado a mi perra y entonces yo
caminaba con mi perra aquí a un lado y
le decía junto y caminaba conmigo y
después me daba la vuelta y la perra me
seguía para todos lados lamentaba la
pelota y no iba hasta que yo le dije que
fuera por la entrene para buscar
personas y entonces fue un éxito
llegamos a buscar personas en el bordo
encontramos gente viva gente fallecida
lamentablemente pero allí nace este
interés por los perros y muchos amigos
me empiezan a decir que si les entrenaba
a sus perros lo hago se los entregó y me
dicen no no sirves
yo bueno está bien otros amigos lo mismo
no me sirvió y yo le decía préstame tu
perro mira ve como lo hacen las
excelentes grandioso
y me decía no no sabes que no me sirvió
gracias pero todo lo hacía por amistad
la verdad es que no les cobraba
absolutamente nada nunca llegué a cobrar
este servicio para poder aprender más y
resulta que me di cuenta que cierto día
me piden que les cobre dije bueno mala
idea porque cuando el perro me lo dejan
y yo lo entrenó el perro hacia unas
cosas maravillosas el perro que entrene
se llamaba luna vivía en los ángeles y
lo habían traído para que yo lo
entrenará regresa una semana después la
persona y me dice sabes que tu
entrenamiento no me sirvió que el una es
una perfecta destruye y entonces dije
bueno déjame ver y entonces agarro al
perro lo empiezo a manejar pero se
maneja muy bien entonces le dije sabes
que deja ver que está fallando y
entonces era él el dueño el que estaba
fallando y ahí decidí entonces entrenar
a los humanos y empezar a perfeccionar
todo esto no había otra teníamos que
trabajar ahora con ellos el perro cerró
el ojo y me dijo cox
me costaba cinco minutos componer un
perro hora y media enseñarle a la
persona cómo tenía que comunicarse con
el perro y esto lo hicimos a través de
varios años modificamos la técnica y le
hicimos en diez temas ya les voy a
platicar
número 1
no hablar del perro es pero nunca te va
a entender la mayoría de las personas
quieren corregir al perro diciéndole
firulais te dije que la manguera no no
me sirve de nada hablar con el perro dos
razón o con el perro firulais por qué lo
hiciste en la mañana te lleve a caminar
a correcto debiste haberte portado muy
bien y no lo hiciste estás castigado
le pongo emociones humanas a mi perro
no le pegues pobre zinc sin defensa
pobrecito velo no le hagas nada no le
grites no le digas nada míralo pobrecito
en la cara triste y el otro ahí abajo
con su mirada y en el piso y haciendo
esto
oye pues todos los perros estando abajo
volteando hacia arriba van a ver como si
estuvieran tristes todos bueno estos
tres elementos los eliminamos que fue lo
que hicimos enseñar a la gente cómo con
su cuerpo podía comunicarse con el perro
y entonces le dije a la gente mira yo
cuando voy en la calle y ve un perro que
me va a morder y reconozco
inmediatamente como el perro gruñe le
enseña los dientes se me va encima le
para los pelos del plomo y se va a
atacarme y digo me va a morder y corro
no creo que haya alguien querido ahí
mira qué bonito perro
está agresivo el perro me está diciendo
que algo está mal que no estoy haciendo
lo correcto y entonces me pongo a salvo
ahora el perro que tiene que ver
igualito con esos cuatro elementos que
ese perro que me agrede utiliza para mí
para decirme lo que no le gusta ahora yo
esos cuatro elementos los utilizo para
decirle al perro lo que no me gusta y
entonces número uno con mi cuerpo lo
amenazó
mi cara salvaje
y la parte física
muévete
no lo toco directamente al perro me
muevo hacia el perro llegó él lo empujó
con un poquito de agresión un poquito
mucho
hago un sonido que es enérgico y el
sonido más enérgico que puede ver es
como la señora en el centro comercial
con el chamaco que va a ir dando lata
ese sonido es super amenazante
cuarto elemento mi mirada
yo me quedo viendo poquito tiempo al
perro le digo no que deje eso y me muevo
dejo de ver al perro porque la mayoría
de las personas lo que hacen es no
no no no no no espera no porque porque
cada vez que yo veo mucho tiempo un
perro pero piensa que estoy practicando
poner que estamos interactuando dice él
pero ya me estás viendo yo te estoy
viendo ya estás viendo y ahora qué
hacemos no se pite brinco de morder
y dice la gente porque tendrá
hiperactividad mi perro
creo que sé porque tiene para actividad
entonces con estos cuatro elementos me
ayudará a decir a la gente cómo
comunicarse con su perro ahora hay otra
parte importante mi perro es conductual
mi perro no entiende lo que le hablo
pero entiende todo lo que mueve mi
cuerpo todo lo que mi cuerpo le dice y
entonces luego dice la gente es que mi
perro bien que sabe cuando ya me voy
pero sabe sabe te lo juro es
inteligentísimo yo como crees y cómo es
eso
si yo agarro la bolsa ganó las llaves
este pongo la alarma y le digo el paro
al rato nos vemos y me salgo dije pues
si yo veo que agarrar la bolsa agarra
las llaves sé que ya te vas no necesitas
decirme ya me voy entonces mi perro ve
lo que hago y aprende y dice a este ya
se va me podía parar en la puerta y el
perro lo primero que hace es pararse así
en la puerta está abierta está la puerta
y el perro ya tiene una nariz seguir y
el otro dice quítate por favor y no se
quita te tengo que quitar es conductual
él sabe que se abre la puerta va a salir
corriendo y poco ya ganó entonces lo que
yo hago es decir a la gente aprende de
la conducta de tu perro y enseñarle a
través de acciones y reacciones él hace
algo tú debes de hacer algo pero ahora
ya no hagas algo agradable para el perro
todo lo que has hecho en tu vida con el
perro es darle todo en positivo y todo
en agradable abre la puerta y lo dejas
que salga corriendo y nunca le llamas
está la atención el perro te salta se
está rascando cuando tu bebé de tres
meses y tú lo empiezas a acariciarle
estas reforzando el que brinque
el perro empieza a ladrar lea un extraño
a una familiar sobre todo a un familiar
el extraño no me importa que se lo coma
pero el familiar le está ladrando guau
guau guau y lo primero que haces es no
mi amor no no no firulais tranquilo
pásale pásala y yo lo agarro yo lo
agarro que no te va a brincar pásale y
entonces firulais dice no pues mira esto
es bueno yo le helado yo quiero atacar
yo quiero morder y entonces él me
acaricia me dice esto es bueno esa es la
conducta es lo que yo hago con mi perro
acción de mi perro reacción mía es
conductual el perro aprende a través de
lo que hace y lo que recibe y de eso
depende que lo siga haciendo o que lo
elimine entonces ahí tienen que si el
perro está mordiendo algo y yo le digo
el perro mira voy a poner un cinturón
aquí y si te veo morder te voy a pegar
me voy al rato regreso y entonces el
perro lo veo que está mordiendo y le
digo porque tú no entiendes hace rato te
dije que no mordía heras ahorita vas a
ver mira voy a agarrar mi cinturón y vas
a ver cómo te va a ir te dije que te iba
a pegar ahorita verás y entonces en
cuanto haya vuelto el perro está sentado
y entonces cuando el perro está sentado
yo agarré el cinturón y lo pegó y le
digo te dije que no more dieras y
entonces mi perro dice algo que me pegó
porque estaba sentado porque no entiende
lo que hablo entiende lo que hace y lo
que hizo fue cambiar la conducta de
morder a sentarse y entonces yo le pegue
no funciona así me voy según yo ya pensé
que lo corregí cuando yo regreso resulta
que el perro está mordiendo y le digo
oye no entendiste eres un burro deberá
ser es necio ahorita vas a ver te voy a
pegar cuando yo hago esto y volteo al
perro está echado y cuando está echado
yo le pego y le digo no vuelvas a morder
mi perro está entendiendo que existe
sienta y que si se echa está mal porque
le estoy pegando pero si muerde está
bien no pasa nada el dueño no le hace
absolutamente nada y entonces aquí es
donde mi perro aprende esto es un
ejemplo no quiero decir que si le tienen
que hacer al perro lo que hace mucha
gente le pega al perro
es malo pegarle al perro porque cuando
le pegan el perro ya no entiende porque
le estás pegando entonces imagínense que
su perro está haciendo una conducta en
la mañana cuando tú te vas a trabajar y
regresas en la tarde le dices adónde
está el perro ve nomás la manguera como
la dejo dónde está el perro y el perro
haya dormido ven acá lo agarras y le
pegas y el perro dice woods no vuelvo a
dormir
cuando escuché que llega el carro de
veras voy a hacer todo lo posible por no
dormirme y ahí tienen un perro que está
como loco todo el día no sé por qué
cuando llego está bien loco está
hiperactivo pues yo sí sé si qué pasa
con porsche por perro no dice no yo y me
duermo y me pegan me siento me pegan
estoy quieto y me pegan entonces lo que
hay que hacer es aprender de esa
conducta y enseñarle a través de esa
conducta a nuestro perro él hace algo yo
hago algo soy conductual él tiene que
entender a través de lo que yo hago cada
vez que él haga algo así es que a partir
de hoy cuando lleguen a su casa quien
tiene perro levanta las manos que tiene
perro donde todos no importa porque no
los veo
pero asumo que todos tienen un perro
y que cuando lleguen a su casa si
quieren corregir al perro no le van a
hablar y no van a razonar con él ni
tampoco van a platicar bueno si pueden
platicar de su vida de ellos platiquen
de todo lo que quieran o le va a decir a
nadie el guarda el secreto súper bien y
aparte se desahogan y sirve de terapia
esto lo hemos venido haciendo de forma
gratuita en muchas colonias en muchas en
muchos lugares para que la gente aprenda
a comunicarse con su perro y entonces a
través de este entrenamiento a los
humanos
el perro sea feliz porque la idea es que
tengamos perros felices y dueños felices
entonces imagínense si el dueño de
aprender a comunicarse de forma correcta
esa armonía va a volver a lo que era
hace muchísimos años más de 100 años
atrás o más todavía hace tres mil años
cuando el perro empezó a integrarse con
el humano en ese entonces se integró por
algo había un interés el interés era
mutuo yo te ayudo tú me ayudas pero era
un entendimiento animal 100% lo que
acabo de explicarles es como los
animales se identifican así se comunican
con agresiones y cuando vienen moviendo
la cola yo lo acarició si viene gruñendo
yo me hago un lado cuando lo cuando lo
humano quiere corregir al perro
regularmente baile dice ahorita te voy a
pegar vas a ver si usted no lo hagan así
puntos sean agresivos y con eso van a
tener un perro excelente sean pacientes
y busquen ayuda profesional si es que no
pueden con estos consejos que acabo de
decir
a veces van a llegar muchos y van a
querer hacer a lo mejor no les va a
salir bien pero ahí hay muchas páginas
hay muchos lugares donde pueden obtener
información muchas gracias por su
atención
[Aplausos]
[Música]